>> Bill: THE QUESTION WHO IS
CROSSING OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
SHOCKING NUMBERS FROM THE
SOUTHWEST.
SO FAR THIS YEAR AGENTS HAVE
REPORTED ENCOUNTERING 50 PEOPLE
WHO ARE LISTED ON THE TERROR
WATCH LIST.
BILL MELUGIN IS LIVE IN
HIDALGO, TEXAS WITH DETAILS.
WHAT DID YOU FIND OUT?
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THESE ARE BRAND-NEW NUMBERS
FROM CBP AND EYE OPENING.
UNDER PRESIDENT BIDEN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE TERROR
WATCH LIST ARRESTED BY BORDER
PATROL HAS SHOT UP
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPARED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LET’S GET RIGHT INTO THE
NUMBERS IF WE CAN PULL UP THE
GRAPHIC.
THIS IS FOR OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
BRAND-NEW CBP NUMBERS SHOWING
ARRESTS ON THE TERRORIST
SCREENING DATABASE SO FAR FOR
FISCAL YEAR 2022 WITH FOUR
MONTHS LEFT 50 ARRESTS BY
BORDER PATROL ON THE TSDB.
PRIOR TO THAT THAT’S UP BIG
OVER 2021.
15.
FISCAL YEAR 19 ZERO, THEN 6 AND
2.
YOU GET THE PICTURE.
THE TREND THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS THE NUMBER OF THESE
ARRESTS HAVE EXPLODED AND THERE
HAVE BEEN 65 ALREADY THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS.
PREVIOUS FOUR YEARS COMBINED
BEFORE THAT THERE WERE ONLY 11.
CASE IN POINT, PEOPLE ALWAYS
TRYING TO SNEAK INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
IF WE CAN PULL UP THE VIDEO WE
EMBEDDED WITH TEXAS DPS A GROUP
OF RUNNERS TRYING TO HOP A
FENCE AND GET AWAY FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
DIDN’T WORK OUT FOR THEM.
THE GROUP OF RUNNERS ARRESTED
BY STATE TROOPERS AND BORDER
PATROL OFF A NEARBY HIGHWAY.
SECOND PIECE OF VIDEO WE
EMBEDDED WITH TEXAS DPS
TROOPERS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT YOU’LL SEE MIGRANT
RUNNERS JUST HIDING IN THE
BRUSH ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THEY SHINE THEIR LIGHTS AND
START POPPING OUT OF THE BRUSH.
NUMEROUS RUNNERS THERE ARRESTED
AS WELL.
THEN THIS LAST PIECE OF VIDEO
WE WANT TO SHOW YOU A PURSUIT
INVOLVING TEXAS STATE TROOPERS
WITH A HUMAN SMUGGLER.
ONE TROOPER GETS BEHIND A GUY
SMUGGLING AT LEAST 10 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND THERE IS A
BAIL-OUT.
THE DRIVER BAILS OUT AND ALL OF
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS START
BAILING OUT OF THE VEHICLE AND
START RUNNING ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
THE TROOPERS OUTNUMBERED.
HE DECIDES TO GO AFTER THE
DRIVER AND TEXAS DPS TELLS ME
HE WAS SUCCESSFUL IN TAKING THE
DRIVER THAT DOWN AND ARRESTING
HIM FOR HUMAN SMUGGLING.
HIGHLIGHTING THOSE TERROR WATCH
LIST NUMBERS IT IS EXTRA
CONCERNING CONSIDERING THE FACT
THAT MULTIPLE CBP SOURCES TELL
ME JUST SINCE OCTOBER MORE THAN
440 KNOWN GOTAWAYS HERE AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
YOU DO THE MATH ON THAT AND
THAT AVERAGES OUT TO 1,800
PEOPLE SLIPPING PAST OUR AGENTS
EVERY DAY.
THE QUESTION IS, WHO ARE THOSE
PEOPLE?
>> Bill: IT’S UNBELIEVABLE,
BILL.
HOW MUCH MONEY WE HAVE SPENT
FOR 20 YEARS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY DO NOT PASS THROUGH OUR
AIRPORTS AND GET ON OUR
AIRPLANES AND THIS COULD BE
HAPPENING EVERY WEEK.
VERY INTERESTING REPORTING
THERE.
STAY ON IT.